I like going to Anime Expo it's always
crazy I mean you just see the most
insane cosplayers yeah it's just very
busy I can't wait to see the amount of
honkai cosplayers this year I'm calling
it now
it's
like all of us have just taken over
cosplays right last year like last year
I was surprised not really surprised
actually kind of surprised because I
knew genshin was big I was not surprised
I don't know okay I knew Genji was big I
didn't know I didn't like a year is like
quite a long time in my mind right uh
because that was was it last year last
year was the first time that we had gone
to conventions yeah again after like
covert and everything and I knew ginshin
was big and it was then that I realized
how big genshin was you know
um and with how big honka I think uh how
big honkai I think is going to be
um that's just gonna like they've just
monopolized pretty much every cosplayer
I mean it's because all their characters
are just so cosplayable it's like it's
like these character designs are built
for costume yeah you know the amount of
cosplayers and artists that don't even
play the games well like yeah I just I
just do it because I like it yeah yeah
do you remember like previous cosplays
uh or previous conventions where there
would always be like that one character
at uh every yeah every convention every
year there was always like a heart
there's always Kirito and Asana yeah
that was way longer yeah for me okay
yeah for me the one the one character I
never understood because I didn't
realize it was this popular was uh jinko
enoshima from Duncan Romper there were
so many and I did not understand why
because I didn't my friendship group
like we had one person that played dang
and Romper I mean hardly talked about it
so I was surprised that
this one particular character was just
this popular and pretty much every anime
convention I went to that year yeah what
and it's only June
Duncan Romford characters just jinko and
Ashima yeah why is that I don't know
another one I always see so much of even
to this day is uh [__] uh yumiko from
um Kaki Guru oh yeah you see that still
to this day so many Kaka goodie cosplays
and I'm like I think when the cosplay is
easy you know like yeah you know that's
an anime that is kind of easy to cost
pretty easy yeah you get a little a
normal school-esque outfit throw on a
wig yeah yeah I think it's it's like a
but junko is not easy yeah was not easy
but I I mean I guess it's easy to wear
as well I guess kind of more the closer
it is to normal attire the easier it is
I'm starting to see a pattern here okay
so junko uh yum Echo yeah uh yuno gaso
from
same characters [__] but also it's also
kind of easy to cosplay Kimiko toga from
my hero Academia as well [__] oh my God
what is it with what is it
cosplay is pretty good though because
you got to do a lot of work you gotta
get the thing yeah yeah yeah yeah like
all the all the cosplays I've seen of
all these characters are [__] sick
like they look so good like I could
never do that [__] obviously but like
yeah it's it's all the insane technology
all the insane characters because
they're like they're just like me for
real oh my God yeah I can fix it
yeah
I don't know yeah yeah it'll be doing it
it'll be all chainsaw man this year oh
yeah [__] I wonder how many Machina
powers easy so yeah we'll see a lot of
it sure there are quite a few aqui
cosplayers already like from the few
conventions we were yeah I thought
chainsaw man was already pretty popular
when I well did you see the um the
mapper thing from the I don't know let's
see I don't know which guy it was he was
just like yeah chainsaw man didn't do as
well as we kind of thought it would do
the Jiu Jitsu kaisin did way better yeah
it was actually a uh commercial flop
yeah yeah like really yeah like they
they I saw in an article like they made
close to no money off of Chainsaw man
yeah
I think they don't even think I think
the article headline that I at least I
saw yeah this is me reading article
headlines and all the Articles like
chainsaw man was a success but didn't
have the same impact that Jiu Jitsu
Tyson did yeah for the company yeah like
for mapper I don't get it
like yeah you know the chainsaw man kind
of uh came and everyone was like yo and
at least in Japan this is not online in
the world this is Japan I was like yo
chainsaw man three months and it was
like okay
and then and but like where's Jiu Jitsu
kaisin it felt like it just wouldn't
leave yeah yeah just felt like it was
and then the movie came out and that was
huge and the movie was a huge commercial
it just felt like Jujutsu kaisen hype
did not die in Japan and then I guess
when I heard that I was like yeah that
does kind of make sense when I when I
think about how it was being in Japan
only not nothing to do with yeah online
discourse or anything like that just
being in Japan Jujitsu kaisen was
[__] everywhere I think what Jesus
Christen did really well was that they
kind of had this like constant stream of
new content happening as well because it
was like the first season happened and
then not too long after that there was
like the movie and in between that there
was lots of promotional stuff and now
like you know second season and all that
kind of stuff whereas chainsaw man it
was kind of just like his 12 episodes
and nothing so far yeah right here's the
weird thing though when did people start
getting hyped over Jujitsu Dyson because
it right away really because it felt
like did you start watching it right
away because it felt like when I was
first started watching like let's say
the first Arc of Jiu-Jitsu kaisen I was
like oh this is a hyped up news Shonen
that uh everyone talked about let's see
what it's about and I'm like oh it's
it's good it's good
um and like not many I didn't really see
much discussion or talk about it and
then it just felt like overnight
everyone was watching it and I was like
when did when what happens or when did
this happen at which stage did everyone
start watching Jiu Jitsu Kaizen because
you know at least I think it was at the
moment when Gojo came out
everything
[Applause]
so right I also think like I when I
watch chainsaw man I I thought it
honestly when I was when you compare
them both you're like
trying to man is maybe a little too much
like in terms of like like you know when
you think about a general audience yeah
yeah like it's it's very sexual very
very sexual very weird it's very weird
the gore is [__] intense which makes
fit for all things that I love and I
really [__] dig it but I could see
how on like a general scale how
something like adjudication would be way
easier to Market yeah yeah you know when
you have these characters and yeah it's
about killing [__] you know there's
not guns and there's not humans being
killed a lot of times it's mainly these
spirits and yeah some of the cast you
know maybe some of them get hurt and
stuff but you know what I mean like it's
it when you sit down and look at it from
like a business perspective it would
make wet it doesn't Mark a lot of sense
in Japan as a whole that something like
Judith geisen would pop off more even
though chance the man was marketed
towards like teenagers here I mean I
feel like that's that's I feel that's
like a reason why I like for example was
so huge yeah yeah because I think on a
broader scale of things it's so much
more aspects to that show that are just
so much easily marketable to as wide of
an audience as possible whereas chainsaw
man I feel a lot of the hype that was
created around chainsaw man was it was
two-part it was the fans of the manga of
Chainsaw man yeah and the fact that map
is it definitely felt yeah definitely
felt like the Western hype for it was
was so much more intense than what I saw
in Japan yeah yeah for sure I also feel
like
it's you know I also feel like chainsaw
man only being 12 episode kind of hurt
it a lot as well yeah like I feel like
that was the biggest Factor because I'm
kind of kind of realizing now especially
with long-running battle Shonen you need
more than 12 episodes to sell a Shonen
show I mean Demon Slayer now one of the
highest grossing anime franchises of all
time uh before episode 18 I remembered
no one really [__] watched Demon
Slayer then suddenly everyone was
watching Demon Slayer because of like
one Banger moment uh in episode 18 and I
remember for that moment I was like you
know I I remember I literally made a
video about Demon Slayer being like Oh I
don't I don't think many people are
watching this when it first came out and
then
um it just blew up overnight and I feel
like something similar happened with Jiu
Jitsu kaisen as well where it kind of
like scene
24. sorry I only had 12 episodes though
right no I had 12.
I mean like Finland Saga now I'm
watching it weekly and I'm like I
already know what's gonna happen but I
love I [__] love that we have 20 like
I can get my teeth in it you know what I
mean 20 24 episodes I'm like I'd buckle
up all right it feels like my watching
it weekly the investment is worth more
yeah yeah I wonder if it's gonna it's
gonna swing around yeah because I feel
like we've chainsaw man it's like the 12
episodes barely got me invested into oh
they didn't they didn't even get like
the meat of the store yet right yeah
yeah it does kind of suck because you
know when they're like all right wait
three years now yeah what yeah exactly
because it's like if I compare the first
12 episodes of Jesus kaisin we're gonna
start a war right now by the way uh if I
compare the first 12 episodes of Jesus
Christ versus the first 12 episodes of
Chainsaw man I would say I'm more for
chainsaw man but now that the final
product is there there were more Banger
moments in Jiu-Jitsu geisen because it
had uh had 24 episodes and uh had some
really really good [__] fights in the
second half which is my favorite part of
the first season of jiu foreign
has even come close to reaching his Peak
which is why it's it's good they're both
good but they're both shows they're both
Shonen shows that in my eyes have not
come close to reaching their full
potential yet it's just a question
season two 24 episodes as well yes
I mean they've been doing it to service
if they only gave you 12 episodes I'd
rather wait yeah I'd rather wait like
three years and get 24 episodes than
wait one year and get 12 episodes
because yeah I I don't know what it is
something about like yeah you you often
can't reach a good climax in 12 episodes
without it feeling rushed for like this
kind of Shonen yeah I mean I feel that's
why like the latest seasons of like
Attack on Titan struggled a lot right
because it's like we were only given
like yeah we get small increments of
like 12 episodes where it would have
just been much better if we just gave us
a huge chunk of 24 episodes to actually
invest ourselves in and now like the
hype for it is like kind of slowly doing
away because it's like oh [__] we have
to wait again yeah the continuation yeah
yeah I'm I'm kind of starting to realize
how unimpactful we were 12 episodes is
because there's a lot there's so many 12
episodes anime that I like but now when
I think about the anime I'm excited
about it's every it's all of them that
have like multiple Seasons yeah yeah
that have a longer ongoing story than
just 12 episodes I'm trying to I'm
trying to think of like imagine if one
percent of the power that one piece
animation had was put into other [__] we
did get so many episodes we've got so
many episodes dude I don't know I I I
yeah I I definitely again like watching
Finland Saga really has made me
appreciate that yeah like I mean map is
animating that yeah the fact they were
given so much time to let that story
breathe and you know because I think
there could have been an argument where
a lot of fans would be like the [__]
far Mark is boring it's not as sure I'm
saying like this is what like maybe
people would say because a lot of people
are worried that anime wouldn't like the
the new season of Inland songs they're
like what the [__] why is nothing
happening yeah yeah um but I I think it
really really helped sell that story in
particular and helps get the message
across by just having this kind of slow
progress and and letting you go through
it in a way that isn't rushed because
because I do think there could have been
a world where it could have been rushed
and it could have been glossed over 12
episodes yeah for sure it wouldn't have
been good but I think it could have been
done well I think the problem is right
now that there is so much anime being
made and most of them aren't doing two
episodes right and most of them are 12
episodes right so
um even if you have a banger 12 episodes
just by having 24 episodes it will stick
out more in people's minds because
they've consumed more of it compared to
like other shows and I'm looking at a
lot of these like 12 episode shows that
I've watched uh and a lot of them I know
like I think the last one that had like
a massive impact was probably like Bocce
the rock you know but that's because it
was like something new you know
I can't really think of a lot of 12
episode shows that stick in people's
mind years after they air you know uh
whereas I think now now like The Meta is
having
I think you know having longer running
series will run over multiple Seasons
yeah yeah and also releasing them in a
way that it makes sense like I mean
again we spoke about this on a prior
podcast but you know JoJo hype was
killed by how it was released on Netflix
yeah yeah and I think if it was if that
was just they were like hold up let's
just wait an extra year and a half or
two years and let's just drop it all in
one go it would have done better or I
think even better yet I I kind of prefer
just the weekly model as the older I've
gotten and the I don't know why the more
I don't I can't the more I kind of like
the weekly Model A lot I'm like yeah I
like this I can get invested over a
course of a long period of time
I [__] myself over with oceanico and
hell's paradise and I hate it I hate
waiting a week for an exit episode you
hate that I like that I just want to
watch the next episode and I think one
of the things I like most about that is
that the show can come out and and I can
reflect on my life as the show is coming
out
mean because like sometimes it's like a
a 50 episode series right yeah and it's
I I can be like damn I've been watching
this for a whole year and I can think
about how that I've had this whole thing
to look forward to and I can think back
to like what where you know where I was
but I I I really like that I don't know
why like being a part of something for
that long is kind of nice yeah
um you know whereas when you binge it I
don't feel the same one piece
I genuinely think like one piece fans
they must get like this because you know
I mean obviously I'm still reading it
but I'm not reading it like weekly but
yeah it must be kind of cool to follow
something like one piece fans who have
been following it for like 10 plus years
it must be pretty [__] cool to follow
one piece and have it kind of Follow
Your like life that's kind of yeah
that's kind of sick I mean as is that
one piece fan and you know also as
someone who's had some franchises that's
happened to me before I think the
biggest one that sticks out my mind is
Ava Ava wasn't exactly a weekly show it
wasn't exactly a weekly wait to get the
next piece of Ava but I waited we were
able fans we waited and you know seeing
it come to an end after a [__] 25 and
then you couldn't imagine how you were
when you first watched the second one
yeah yeah yeah and you look back but you
know cool I I don't I don't I feel like
a year is not enough time for me to be
like emotionally invested enough to be
like oh I I watched that so much changes
in a year I think it's important to
self-reflect on your past year because
like for me uh my biggest thing I look
for whenever I watch anything doesn't
even matter which if it's animes just to
get like immersed in the story right of
course that's why I kind of I'm fine
with watching us TV shows a lot of time
weekly because they're like an hour long
20 minutes is barely enough it's not
enough yeah yeah it's barely enough time
for me to like properly get immersed in
a story which is which is why I love it
then because I feel super good that when
I maybe one week I was super busy and I
couldn't watch the show and then you
have two episodes to watch you like oh
yeah
oh yeah grab some popcorn get a drink 40
minutes yes
someone else must be relating to this
it's certainly it's just a treat when
you know I I get I get the sentiment
yeah it's so nice
yeah and I'm sure we'll be like that for
me because I'm gonna try my goddamn
hardest to not watch for the first few
weeks so that I can because you know a
lot of anime suffer from the first few
episodes
it's like my personal rule with Demon
Slayer uh from like the past like from
the second Arc onwards I was like I'm
not watching a goddamn episode until
episode 8 is out yeah because it's it's
usually a blue ball to till episode
eight yeah like nothing happens most of
the time uh except the the sawdark a lot
I did that rule and then like two
episodes in stuff started happening I
was like oh okay that's good I just wait
till the whole season's over so I can
just binge it yeah I need at least like
five five abs so it's I watched like
five episodes that's how I get properly
hooked yeah but I have that five or six
episode binge yeah and then I can be
like now I'm ready to wait weekly
because I know it's worth it now with
Shonen it's it's okay there are some
series I can maybe like bend the rules
and watch weekly Shonen is my own
impossible because the amount of times
I've tried this before where I've
watched it it's the first episode of the
fights you are just getting invested and
you're like damn shit's about to shit's
about to pop off episode ends so you
wait a week you're like I've forgotten
what's happened oh yeah they're in a
fight okay let's let's it's about to pop
off and then there's always like the
there's always like the three-stage act
in the fight where at first it looks
like you know things are going well or
maybe the maybe this time the
protagonist is losing and you're in my
mind I'm just like okay I'm waiting for
the episode where the protagonist turns
it around yeah and it's not that episode
it's the next episode so I gotta invest
myself again wait a week and then in a
single fight last three [__] week so
I'm like
I didn't even I I heard third part is uh
protagonist makes a realization about
themselves yeah and uses that knowledge
to fight yeah and I'm like [__] this is
enough this is enough time for me to use
my brain you know I'm like I know what's
going to happen uh and you know it's
it's not enough time to like reinvest
back into that fight to really see the
hype moment where the protagonist turns
it around or that hype moment happens in
the fight you know especially with
Shonen there needs to be like a natural
progression in the fight for both you
the
rocky the rock is like yeah I could
watch that Weekly uh I'm just like yeah
turn my brain off because nothing
[__] happens that's why
but she's scared oh she's just like me
for real okay that's enough yeah it's
yeah they're definitely not Shonen but
uh that's why I kind of I I like the
Netflix model
even though I would still like them to
release weekly just because
I would you know I have patience I can
wait until this
yeah I I I can wait